so it turns out that the real life story
in The Blind Side might not be so real
if you've been living under a rock for
the last hundred years it turns out that
Hollywood might not be the most
reputable source of information now you
might remember the 2009 movie The Blind
Side which was reportedly based on the
true story of Michael Orr who was lifted
out of grinding poverty after being
taken in by a wealthy Tennessee couple
Sean and Leanne Tui thanks to their
support or graduated high school got a
scholarship to play football at the
tui's alma mater Ole Miss and was
selected by the Baltimore Ravens in the
first round of the 2009 NFL draft over
eight seasons were played for three NFL
teams as an offensive tackle and made
two Super Bowl appearances bringing home
one Super Bowl ring the movie earned
over 300 million dollars the box office
and was nominated for best picture while
Sandra Bullock took home best actress
for her portrayal of Leanne Tui and of
course one of the things that makes the
film's message so heartwarming is how
the two is not only treated or like
family they legally adopted him into it
we want to know if you would like to
become part of this family
foreign
[Music]
but perhaps you can't believe everything
that comes out of Hollywood according to
a 14-page petition filed in Tennessee
probate court or alleges that the tuis
tricked him into signing a document he
thought legally made them his adopted
parents but actually made them his
conservatives which purportedly allowed
them to enter into business deals in his
name and make millions of dollars off of
his life but in response to the lawsuit
the Tui family lawyers denied Orr's
allegations of exploitation calling them
hurtful and absurd and one of their
lawyers also accused or of only filing
the petition after the toys reviews to
pay 15 million dollars as part of a
Shakedown effort or settlement agreement
depending on which side you are on but
let's talk about these allegations and
let's talk about what it means that the
tuis had a conservatorship over Michael
Orr under Tennessee law a
conservatorship is a legal proceeding in
which a court strips the decision-making
ability from someone who is a minor or
lacks the legal capacity to make
decisions on their own and transfers
that ability to one or more
conservatives a conservative is not a
member of the family and can consent to
the conservatorship by signing the
proper legal documents and also under
Tennessee law conservators have a
fiduciary relationship with their
conservatives and with great
conservative power comes great legal
responsibility and specific legal duties
to the conservative including a duty to
act only in the best interest of the
conservative manage the conservatives
money properly and carefully keep the
conservatives money and property
separate from the conservators and
maintain Good Records now fiduciaries
also must act in a manner that is
trustworthy honest and in good faith
those that fail to abide by these
standards can be sued and forced to
repay the money in contrast in adoptions
an adoptee becomes a permanent member of
the family and the parents are legal
Guardians under Tennessee law but
parents don't have the same strict
duties to their children as conservators
do to their Wards or for the same length
of time Tennessee parents have a duty
for the care nurture welfare education
and support of their minor children
until the child graduates high school or
if 18 completes their current grade so
here on August 14 2023 Michael Orr filed
a 14-page petition to terminate
conservatorship for accounting and other
relief in Shelby County Tennessee
probate court now petition makes two
main claims first that the tuis
fraudulently induced ore into consenting
into a conservatorship by
misrepresenting the documents as adult
adoption papers tricking him into giving
them control over his Affairs and second
that the tuis have abused their
positions as fiduciaries to profit off
of ore's life and likeness for financial
gain including by falsely holding out to
the world that they legally adopted or
as their son now ore's petition which is
obviously going to be from his side of
the story describes a tragic story that
led to him being taken in by the tuis
some of which was depicted in The Blind
Side albeit with some dramatic license
on April 14 1996 or one of a dozen
siblings became a ward of the Tennessee
Foster system just before turning 12
years old or bounced around between the
foster care system and being homeless
attending 11 schools in nine years and
repeating the first and second grades
with the help of a friend's father or
was admitted to Briarcrest Christian
School as a sophomore for the fall of
2002. by fall of 2003 Orr began playing
basketball and football and his talent
was apparently immediately recognized
eyes resulting in football scholarship
offers pouring in from top colleges in
the film several college football
coaches Cameo as themselves to depict
their efforts to recruit or hello I'm
Tommy tuberville Auburn University
Leanne Tui nice to meet you Michael yes
that's right before he was the U.S
senator single-handedly undermining
America's military Readiness Tommy
duberville got himself an IMDb Credit in
an oscar-winning film or explained that
he was near penniless and got by thanks
to the kindness of relatives friends and
others letting him stay in their homes
beginning in the summer of 2004 or would
occasionally stay with Sean and Leanne
Tui and here's how The Blind Side
depicts their decision to welcome ore
into their home beginning in the summer
of 2004. I think what you're doing is so
great to open up your home to him and
honey you're changing that boy's life
no
he's changing mind but Ora's petition
portrays the tui's motives as anything
but altruistic a quote where other
parents of Michael's classmates saw
Michael simply as a nice kid in need
conservators Sean Tui and Leanne Tui saw
something else a gullible young man
whose athletic Talent could be exploited
for their own benefit in the petition or
asserts that the tuis told him that they
loved him encouraged him to refer to
them as Mom and Dad which he did and
promised that they would go through the
process of Legally adopting him into
their family except that or was never
legally adopted quote almost immediately
after Michael moved in the tuis
presented him with what he understood to
be legal papers that were a necessary
step in the adoption process Michael
trusted the tuis and signs where they
told him to sign what he signed however
and unknown to Michael until after
February 2023 were not adoption papers
or the equivalent of adoption papers
instead it was the petition for
appointment of conservators which was
filed in this cause on August 9 2004 by
Deborah Brennan attorney of record in
this matter Miss Brown and was so close
to the Tui family that Michael was
encouraged to refer to her as Aunt
Debbie now according to Orr the original
August 9 2004 conservatorship petition
states that he quote shall not be
allowed to enter into any contracts or
bind himself without the direct approval
of his guardian conservators and he will
quote not be allowed to make medical
decisions for himself and as for the
tuis they quote shall have all Powers of
Attorney to enter into contracts for or
they quote shall have full and complete
authority to make medical and
educational decisions on Orr's behalf
and they shall have quote full and
complete access to all his medical and
school records in the same vein as had
they been his natural parents and
Guardians now one of the things that's
curious here is the petition's
acknowledgment that or lack the typical
criteria for being placed in a
conservatorship given that he had no
diagnosed physical or psychological
disabilities was 18 years old and would
graduate from high school within the
year and furthermore while the original
conservatorship petition stated it was
Orr's decision to end the
conservatorship by age 25 at the latest
the final order granted allowed the tuis
to serve until the court decided to
terminate the conservatorship or alleged
that the tuis never told him that they
were assuming sweeping authority over
ore's life and claims that he had been
told that this conservatorship petition
was required because he was over the age
of 18 and that this document was quote
for all intents and purposes and
adoption now we'll get into the veracity
of this purported statement that you
can't adopt an adult in Tennessee in a
moment but or further alleges that the
tuis have enriched themselves in aura's
expense based on quote the LIE of
Michael's adoption appointing to Leanne
to his personal website and their
charitable organization the making it
happen Foundation as examples it appears
that Leanne Tui explicitly refers to or
as her adopted son in marketing for her
foundation and as a motivational speaker
now regarding the financial exploitation
or claims that the tuis have been
unjustly enriched from their association
with him and excluded him from profits
from The Blindside movie the petition
alleges that the tuis began negotiating
a movie deal about their relationship
with the war shortly after the release
of the 2006 book The Blind Side
evolution of the game by Michael Lewis
who happens to be a close school friend
of Sean Tui now the petition also claims
that the movie paid the twoies and their
two birth children each 225 thousand
dollars plus 2.5 percent of the films
defined net proceeds now the petition
notes that while four of the Tui family
members had the same representative at
the creative artist agency or CAA the
agent authorized to receive the movie
contract and payment notices for or is
Debbie braunton the attorney of record
from the conservatorship filing and
close friend of the tuis and of course
the film went on to earn over 300
million dollars at the box office and
tens of millions of more in home video
sales probably due to outstanding
character writing like this there's
something you should know about me
I don't usually tell many people but
it's something I feel you should be
aware of before you hire me
what is it
I'm a Democrat
okay the petition further alleges that a
separate 2007 contract reportedly signed
by or appears to quote give away to 20th
Century Fox quote without any payment
whatsoever the Perpetual unconditional
and exclusive right to use ore's name
likeness voice appearance personality
and personal experiences the filing
states that or has no recollection of
signing this contract but if he did no
one explained the implications of what
he was signing the position also alleges
that Alcon entertainment LLC the
successor to Fox donated 200 000 to
Leanne's making it happen foundation in
October of 2010 which Orr believes came
from a quote amendment to life story
rights agreement or a search that the
tui's never informed ore of any
amendment to his life rights agreement
nor did they secure any amendment that
would ensure or otherwise benefited from
the movie's success now of course if you
ever found yourself in a concert ship
like Michael Orr or Britney Spears you'd
probably need a good lawyer to get out
of it but if you want a great lawyer my
firm the eagle team can help if you've
had an injury or death in the family
suffered a data breach or dealing with
Social Security Disability or workers
comp we can represent you or help find
you the right attorney who can just
click on link in the description for a
free consultation with my team because
you don't just need a legal team you
need the eagle team the link is below
now back to Michael Oher and The Blind
Side so Orr contends that the tuis have
breached several of their duties as
conservatives with their failure to file
any yearly accounting of the
conservatorship spending and assets
including Orr's life rights file any
statement relating to orders mental or
physical condition as to whether the
conservative ship should continue as
required by Tennessee law and to act in
ore's best interest as required for
fiduciaries so Ora's petition asked the
court to end the tui's conservatorship
and to issue an injunction barring them
from using his name and likeness it also
seeks a full accounting of the money
that the two is earned using ore's name
and to have the couple pay him his fair
share of profits as well as unspecified
court costs attorneys fees and
compensatory and punitive damages
now in response to the petition
attorneys representing the tuis of
course denied ore's claims of deception
and financial exploitation in a lengthy
statement famed attorney to the star's
Marty singer described the oars
allegations as outlandish hurtful and
absurd unquote the idea that the tuis
have ever sought to profit off of
Michael Oher is not only offensive it is
transparently ridiculous the notion that
a couple worth hundreds of millions of
dollars would connive to withhold a few
thousand dollars in profit participation
payments from anyone let alone from
someone they loved as a son defies
belief a singer claimed that the
documentation in the form of profit
participation checks and Studio
accounting statements would demonstrate
that the twois have given Mr Orr an
equal cut of every penny received from
The Blind Side a singer also accused ore
of engaging in a pre-lawsuit Shakedown
claiming the ex-nfl star threatened to
plant a negative story about the tuis in
the Press unless they paid him 15
million dollars singer also asserted
that quote as part of the Shakedown
effort or stopped cashing the royalty
checks from The Blind Side even as the
tuis continue to deposit Orr's money
into a trust account they set up for him
with respect to the conservative ship
singer asserts that there was nothing
underhanded about the arrangement and no
money was made from it quote in spite of
the false allegation in the lawsuit the
tuis have always been upfront about how
a conservatorship from which not one
penny was received was established to
assist with Mr Orr's needs ranging from
getting him health insurance and
obtaining a driver's license to helping
with college admissions should Mr Orr
wish to terminate the conservatorship
either now or at any time in the future
the tuis will never oppose it in any way
and as for the two-way singer asserts
that they are heartbroken over these
events and hope that they can be
reconciled someday and in August 16th
press conference the two is local
Council Randall Fishman and Stephen
farizi further disputed claims that the
family exploited or financially through
the conservatorship the two ways did not
control
any of Mr Orr's finances Mr Orr picked
his own agent
when he signed Pro Mr Orr signed his own
contract
and negotiated it through its agents the
attorneys also insisted that each of the
five family members including Orr
received an estimated one hundred
thousand dollars from The Blind Side
quote Michael got every dime every dime
he had coming Fishman also claimed that
Orr knew he was not legally adopted by
the tuis much earlier than February 2023
noting that Orr had acknowledged the
conservatorship on three separate
occasions uh in particular in his book
and here's how or described the
arrangement in his best-selling Memoir I
beat the odds quote it kind of felt like
a formality as I'd been a part of the
family for more than a year at that
point since I was already over the age
of 18 and considered an adult by the
state of Tennessee Sean and Leanne would
be named as my legal conservators they
explained to me that it means pretty
much the exact same thing as adoptive
parents but the laws were just written
in a way that took my age into account
asked why or was not legally adopted
Fishman said quote it didn't make any
difference to the tuis and added quote
there was one thing to accomplish and
that was to make him part of the family
so the NCAA would be satisfied because
Sean would have been a booster of the
University after the legal team's
presscon conference Orr's Council
provided the following statement quote
we continue to stand with Michael and
the statement he released we also concur
with his attorney Don Barrett we believe
that Justice will be served in the
courtroom where cases are based on facts
now in response to Orr's allegations
Sean Tui deny the claims of financial
exploitation saying quote we didn't make
any money off the movie he said that
Michael Lewis shown to his childhood
friend who wrote the book on which the
film is based gave his family half of
the share of profits from the book Tui
said each member of the family including
or received an equal share of about
fourteen thousand dollars quote we were
never offered money we'd never asked for
money my money is well documented you
can look up how much I sold my company
for Tui also said that he would of
course end the conservatorship for or
between defended placing ore into a
conservatorship instead of adopting him
citing advice of counsel quote Michael
was obviously living with us for a long
time and the NCAA didn't like that they
said the only way Michael could go to
Ole Miss was if he was actually part of
the family I sat Michael down and told
him if you're planning to go to Ole Miss
or even considering Ole Miss we think
you have to be part of the family this
would do that legally we contacted
lawyers who told us that we couldn't
adopt him over the age of 18. the only
thing we could do was to have a
conservatorship we were so concerned it
was on the up and up that we made sure
the biological mother came to court and
the film does show why an NCAA
investigator had concerns that the tuis
May indeed have ulterior motives in
taking him in the NCAA fears that with
your recruitment
a door might be opened that boosters
from lots of schools in the South will
become legal guardians of young athletes
without means and funnel them to their
Alma maters they clothed you they fed
you they paid for your private education
they bought you a car and paid for a
tutor all is part of a plan to ensure
that you play football for the
University of Mississippi
[Music]
however tweets claim that you can't
adopt an adult is categorically false
Tennessee is one of the 29 States plus
the District of Columbia that allows the
adoption of adults in fact the process
is easier when the adoptee is over 18 it
only requires their consent so either
Sean isn't telling the truth or multiple
lawyers gave him bad advice or if
there's some other reason possibly
related to the NCAA that we don't know
about and if lawyers really did give
that advice then the toys should
probably ask for a refund now as always
we need to know that Orr's claims are
merely allegations unless and until
evaluated by a court of law and the same
goes for the two exacusations against
ore but based on the information
available here's what we know and what
we don't know for starters both sides
agree that Orr was placed into a
conservatorship and both sides agree
that Orr was told perhaps incorrectly
that this was effectively the same as
legal adoption and had to be done
because you cannot legally adopt an
adult in Tennessee now we don't know
whether this is a case of negligent
lawyering or malicious intent or
something else and also the
conservatorship order is just odd in
many ways for example it tacitly
acknowledges that or has none of the
traditional qualities that would make
him a candidate for conservatorship or
was 18 years old and not a minor he had
no known physical or psychological
disabilities and yet the conservatorship
ordered robs or of his contractual
autonomy and explicitly states that or
quote shall not be allowed to enter into
any contracts or bind himself without
the direct approval of his conservators
it also provides that any and all
medical decisions shall be made by The
conservators Who will have full and
complete authority to make these
decisions and educational decisions on
Orr's behalf in other words the narrow
purpose of the conservative espoused by
the Tui family doesn't really comport
with the sweeping powers granted to them
over ore and if the tui's goals were
really just to help or get a driver's
license in health insurance placing an
18 year old into a conservatorship of
undetermined length is a very
heavy-handed way of accomplishing that
and as for claims of financial
exploitation by the conservatorship
inaccurate accounting should clarify if
the family did in fact earn money
through the conservatorship that was due
to Michael Oher that he never received
and we don't know the virus divorce
claims that the tuis through trickery or
forgery got him to sign away his life
rights for nothing and it's also unclear
if the twos were falsely claiming that
they legally adopted him for profit or
if they were figuratively declaring him
their son due to a close familial
relationship even if no paperwork to
that effect had been filed and how would
you refer to someone who is under your
conservatorship uh under these
circumstances and on top of that while
the toys claim that they had
conservatorship power over or they never
really exercised that with respect to
his contractual rights once he went to
college this should be a very easy claim
to prove or disprove and it's also
possible that a lot of these questions
are going to be answered in Discovery we
just simply don't know what the answers
are right now to that effect Orr has
propounded Discovery requests that will
probably help illuminate which side
story is more credible or has issued
expansive subpoenas to the make it
happen foundation and attorney Deborah
bronnen seeking among other things all
documents and Communications related to
The Blind Side and the circumstances
surrounding Ora's conservatorship in a
full Financial Accounting of Leann's
charitable foundation and this also may
be a case of seeking money that never
existed the producers of The Blind Side
movie who run alkaline entertainment
said that the contracts quote did not
include significant payouts in the event
of the film's success and therefore
quote the notion that the twois were
paid millions of dollars by Alcon to the
detriment of Michael Oher is false and
evidently the producers paid out about
767 thousand dollars to the talent
agency representing the tuis and or but
they noted that there was likely an
agency commission removed before the sum
was distributed to the five members of
the family so it's unclear who's telling
the truth and what happened here there
may be an assumption by or that because
the movie earned 300 million dollars at
the box office that the movie made more
money than it actually did but don't get
me started about Hollywood accounting
there's lots of wildly successful movies
that are in the red because of the way
that they are accounted for and reminder
that's one of the reasons why sag-aftra
is currently boycotting right now but
it's also weird that the toys used a
conservative one that continues to this
day now if you spend any time on the
internet it can feel like you're in a
conservatorship if your personal data is
being used by nefarious people but you
can get your online personal data taken
down with today's sponsor in cogni now I
don't know about you but I've seen a
huge uptick in the amount of spam I'm
getting and it's no surprise why every
year the number and scope of data
breaches worldwide is rising and you
might not know it but there are hundreds
of data Brokers out there that possess
and sell your personal information and
their numbers grow every year these data
Brokers might have a whole Shadow
profile on you including your name your
address phone number shopping habits
possibly even your social security
number all up for the highest bidder and
at best this leads to scam calls and at
worst identity theft and doxy so for
example if you're getting tons of Robo
calls your cell phone or calls from
scammers like I am basically every day
there's a good chance that that's
because your data is online and
sometimes it's completely legal but
totally nefarious like health insurance
companies raising their rates because
they got access to your personal health
data but that's where incognate comes in
incognitive fights on your behalf to
remove your personal data from data
Brokers and deals with any objections
from their side all you have to do is
create an account and give them approval
to work on your behalf and then incogni
conducts repeated ongoing removals
because even if the broker removes your
data once they might collect it again
which is just so dumb but in cognitive
make sure that your personal information
stays off the market for good you can
actually see when Incognito does this on
your personal dashboard this is mine it
shows that these three sites had data on
me that was rated 10 out of 10 on
incognito's sensitivity scale and those
Brokers had my data including my
contacts my financial data and Health
Data and thankfully incogni told me when
their removal requests were completed so
I could breathe easily it was terrifying
to see exactly how many Brokers had my
data but it's really fun to watch
incogni get them to delete that info one
by one and it shows up immediately on
your dashboard so if you'd like to give
Incognito try click on the link below to
get 60 off incogni when you use the code
legal eagle again to get an exclusive 60
off discount just click on the link
that's on screen right now or down in
the description and use the code legal
eagle after that click on this link over
here for more legal eagle or I'll see
you in court